welcome back to cbs this morning we are
hearing from the first two medical
workers to get the coronavirus vaccine
in america
outside the clinical trials they are icu
nurse at sandra lindsay
she became the first person to receive
the vaccine in this country yesterday
this is a big deal
she is also the director of critical
care nursing at long island jewish
medical center right here in new york
shortly after that dr eve durosso also
got the vaccine too
he's the chair of emergency medicine at
lennox hill hospital
right here in new york city too they
both join us now good morning to you
both you know the big question everybody
wants to know right off the bat
is how are you feeling sandra start us
off any side effects any any
complications whatsoever it doesn't seem
like it looking at your pretty face and
smile
good morning galen thanks for having us
on i feel great this morning
and i just want to put great in
perspective for people and
so grade is at the injection site on a
scale of one to ten
my pain level is a one and this morning
i just took my temperature
just you know for the hell of it to see
what's happening
what was your temperature for the hell
of it what was it 98.1
oh very good i i really feel
great all right dr eve how are you
feeling
absolutely i second uh exactly what
sandra said i feel great just a little
minor soreness
at the sight of the injection and
otherwise i don't feel feverish i have
no aches and pains everything is feeling
great
sandra you know yesterday i was so
struck by your video because you
literally applaud it in the chair
and i'm wondering at that moment what
were you thinking and why did you want
to be one of the first people to get the
injection
because i think as a healthcare
professional
it's my duty to preserve public health
and i see this as a step in the right
direction
just a small part of what i can do to
put an
end to the pandemic i chaired because i
felt a huge sense of relief
not just for myself but for healthcare
workers
essential workers and everyone that has
been
doing a yeoman's job with putting an
end to this pandemic so i feel hopeful
i see the finish line the light is
brighter in the tunnel
and i just want to tell people don't
look back it's like running a race
you look back you're going to fall
behind but there is still
a lot of skepticism out there what do
you say to people that just think
nope you guys rushed it the medical
community rushed it too fast
and corners were cut i think what we
have to continue to do is message that
the science is behind this vaccination
that this is a new technology it's a
different than the old technology that
required
eggs to grow the vaccinations and that's
why it
actually came about more quickly and
more efficiently
this is actually great news that's not
being picked up this may actually help
us
in the future with the development of
vaccinations
but i would add that we've been through
so much we just absolutely been through
a lot we are still going through a lot
yeah we're still in it too many lives
every day
so this is the hope that we we have in
front of us and we just have to
encourage people to take it
yeah that's what my doctor said to me
yesterday she said gail you have to look
at the science
they don't cut corners with the science
and i'm very very focused on that
and she said you have to get over this
fear of needles you got to just let that
go
here's the other question just yesterday
there was a guy at
costco i believe in california who went
nuts saying that this is all a hoax
that coronavirus doesn't exist you two
have both lost family members to covet
the death toll is now well over three
hundred thousand what do you say when
you hear
that kind of response and considering
the work that you do
sandra so we just have to keep educating
people that it's real
we've lived it we continue to see it
and that it's not a hoax they should
listen to the experts
listen to all the healthcare workers who
have come on before
us to share their story that
it's it's incredibly dark and it is not
a hoax
it is real what was the feeling among
your co-workers yesterday as
as they watched you all take the take
the uh
take the injection and the conversation
yesterday at your respective hospitals
so they're incredibly proud of us and
i've had people come up to me and say
you know i was planning to put off and
wait
but i i was so inspired by your
story and your courage and your bravery
that i can't wait to get the shot now
um i am ready i am like you i am ready
to put an
end to this pandemic well i have to say
this andre whenever they talk about
getting
the shot here in this country your face
is the one we'll see
dr even any closing comment from you
yes i thank you for this opportunity one
thing that we really have to emphasize
is the importance of continuing to do uh
what we've been doing the whole time
and that's wearing our mask washing our
hands social distancing
and please please if at all we could
refrain from gathering
uh this is this and the combination of
taking the vaccination
is what's gonna get us to the end of
this nightmare all right
i've heard it saunders said it's finally
light at the end of a very dark tunnel
we thank you both we thank you thank you
gail
thank you